there's there's pieces you can add
if you offer them it here
you're doing the
you're doing the wrong you're doing the
wrong technique
because it's natural if it's coming like
that
it's downwards isn't it it's downwards
if he's coming here
then you've got a chance to all right so
what
i found is
i'm so busy here that i get a little bit
stuck here it's a bit stuck now to get
this big lump through here
so
i'm not very elegant of that
so i need a little more space
so this is for the for the hakama
when he comes here i'm going to push him
to the stage without him knowing it
to give me a bit more space
it
it's not so much pushing him as it's
holding him off
from cut for this arm coming inwards
so i go like that
and that so i actually put a little bit
of that into it i'm not trying to move
it
but i'm trying to
do that i'm trying to do that
all right you coke you
you can put coke you in once you've got
it but you've got to but but this is uh
domineering and it could be a bullying
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to hold him off because i need
to
so i don't know how you're finding that
your body's too big to get through the
hole you're creating
but if you are
that's what you you need to add that
little piece you know teachers don't
tell you this stuff because uh
they might not know you're struggling
with it
um if you train every day then i used to
do six days a week but
it it gets in being built uh
self-preservance
so but but you know i'm handing you it
do that don't think that oh i'll go
around it all and then you find oh this
is a bit difficult nevermind i'll get
him when i get here now i'll do a nickel
that'll give him that would tell him not
to be so difficult with me
so i'd like to uh
the lady
yeah
and uh let's say
david he's big isn't he all right stand
there please that's right i just need
you to stand there
and david stand there
and
uh let's have a look uh
uh
we'll use you your third down
you stand here
okay so i want you to face him as if
you're gonna now be his ukis
all right so you're ready to be azukis
i'm now going to ask
uh
a genuine question
and i'm asking you all the same question
who are you going to be more bothered
about
this one
let's face it we know don't we
and that's why you'll never be able to
do a sense of zyka though
because you've decided
who is going to give you the biggest
problem
if this person here
thinks i'll have to blend with either
whatever comes and if he genuinely
genuinely means that that i doubt any of
you do in this room
we haven't found those senses aikido yet
all right so you don't have to attack
him but that was a principle
thank you
so so
your biggest fault in what you're trying
to do in any of these techniques is
you're trying to
work the person out rather than blend
with what you've got
you see form can be a hindrance as well
as
uh helpful
it doesn't matter who
comes up like i said i haven't trained
with dominique i haven't trained with
roger it doesn't matter to me
because i must
be polite to them
please go past